was that your first home yes i forget
how i found out that that was your house
i feel like maybe my someone told my
girl and we were driving by my girl said
oh that's you know west coast and i
thought cool yeah a lot of people found
out because i
threw a party during the pandemic and
then it was like
yeah everybody kind of found out i saw
that on tmz that's where i get my news
yeah some somebody said some [ __ ] who
was in my party
sent the video to tmz and i'm just like
okay i've gotta be way more strict with
my guest list next time yeah afterwards
or during the party uh during the party
they they from in my living room took a
video and then sent it to tmz yeah and
you know who it was no i don't know who
was oh
damn yeah i was pissed guy hickey yeah
he can find out yeah we gotta track this
person down make sure they're not on the
list we were just putting it out there
we were super coveted safe like it was
so that day not one person walked in
without getting their temperature
checked every single person passed the
temperature check isn't that the point
of those things i remember this party
because like this party none of the
party that she's talking about it was
like noon they were like 11 in the
morning
like
and there were
insane amounts of trucks they were
bringing in like all kinds of like it
was like a big ass like party yeah i
take my parties really serious um but i
guess i was wasn't supposed to take my
party seriously during a pandemic yeah
wow trucks what kind of catering trucks
yeah you know just like i'm all about
the decorations and like having like fun
little games for people to play at the
party and stuff like that did anybody
try to use your black paper towels at
the party
i'm [ __ ] down for those and i don't
know why they don't have different
colored towels periods they should be
more common um i love the black paper
towels the only thing that sucks is like
if you're trying to like clean up
something dirty you can't see like how
good you've cleaned it up on the black
so you actually use them yeah yeah can i
just tell you how [ __ ] up my new tour
is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats